I think the most important issue to make
sure we address here is that we picked
the right problem solved they've been
many examples the last few years of
entities governments and regulators
solving problems which in retrospect
were the wrong problem to solve for
example maintaining quarterly earnings
every quarter and not thinking about
long-term value creation for example
thinking about exchange controls had the
effect of making money leave rather than
money stay the other one I make sure we
figure out is leverage
money was the big thing that people did
for 20 years to devastating consequences
I think the great levering opportunity
now to celebra people you think about
the great wealth creation exercises
either at the corporate or national
level in the last five years we've all
involved entities who will be most
amazing but so is Singapore China and
figured out how to pick the right from
the salt and get human beings to go
after that problem rather than use money
to maintain that sustainable proposition
those are the two big things we need to
work out going forward